it's taken seven years to construct but
investors say it's been worth the wait
and for Nigerians who've struggled with
fuel shortages for decades hope that the
refinery marks a turning point a notable
milestone for our economy and a game
changer
for the downstream petroleum Florida's
Mighty not only in Nigeria
with the entire African continent
the presence of five African presidents
at the launch underline the expectations
of a continent dependent on fuel Imports
our our products will satisfy the local
demand of Nigeria and it will satisfy
the local demand of most West African
countries and will be able to export
even central Africa Angola
Congo Brazil and Co so you know it's a
very huge capacity 40 of our production
only for exports for decades Nigeria
exported its crude oil only to import
the more expensive refined product back
Africa's biggest oil producer is unable
to refine its crude oil so it's looking
at this Refinery to help millions of
Nigerians are unhappy about higher fuel
cost they also hope the plant will ease
shortages and end the country's
petroleum subsidy program that they say
cost taxpayers tens of billions of
dollars every year
the state-owned Nigerian oil company
which has a 20 stake in the plant will
supply nearly half of their refinery's
daily code needs
so we have secured access to supplying
this to 500 300 000 barrels of crude oil
every day that means a secure market for
nmps as our production grows our
capacity growth as a company so this is
a very very public situation for our
company
the 19 billion dollar Refinery is
expected to save Nigeria the 23 billion
dollars it's spent on important refined
petroleum products in 2022. we are
asserting that it will ease up a lot of
the constraints that we've encountered
in doing business in Africa especially
manufacturing and in transportation
environmentally say they are worried
about the pace at which fossil fuels are
being exploited and used
this causing so much negative impact on
the environment with the oil spills when
you extract with the gas flaring and
also just the combustion of the fossil
fuel it's causing tremendous issues in
the atmospheric balances
but Nigeria like most African oil
producers is making a case for a slower
transition from fossils to renewable
energy
it says petroleum will continue to be in
its energy mix as it makes that
transition Ahmed Idris Al Jazeera
Nigeria